all right people it is thursday
september 16 2021 i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report direct message and in
reality it's actually september 15th i'm
pre-taping today's show because today
the 16th is yom kippur it's the holiest
day of the jewish year and i'm a temple
trying to be a decent human being as
always guys share subscribe click
click that notification bell and all
that good stuff uh we are doing a q a
today i'm going to talk a little bit
more about the cali recall election i'm
actually wearing the same clothes i wore
on the show yesterday so you really know
it's the same day uh and then and then
we're going to move forward from from
the california election um but i wanted
to just touch on a few other little
things and then some q a which is
obviously pretty heavy about the
election and the recall and then about
some other stuff before i do any of that
i want to talk to you guys about bonner
private wine you know here's a crazy
story down in argentina they have
vineyards up at around 9000 feet almost
unheard of for wine making yet they make
world-class like 90-point wine there but
these wines are almost impossible to get
in the u.s these wines come from deep
within the andes mountains made by the
same families for over 200 years the
stories i've heard
it's no wonder how they even get bottles
down from the mountains heck one of the
founders almost died trying to find
these remote vineyards needless to say
these wines are very special they taste
incredible notes of blackberry dark
cherry leather smoke they pair great
with steak i personally like to drink
the malbec you've seen it many times
right here i recommend that you head on
over to freethinkerwine.com you'll find
a mile back from the third highest
vineyard in the world that's almost 9
000 feet no inflated prices you're
getting top quality wine for about half
the price plus my audience gets 50 off
today no promo code necessary just head
to
freethinkerwine.com that's
freethinkerwine.com
and now back to me okay so let's just
roll two clips uh one of the
once and future king of california gavin
newsom and then one of a good decent man
who the media and big tech and the
democrats treated just horribly larry
elder first newsom after he won the
recall election no it's not the only
thing that was expressed tonight i want
to focus on what we said yes to
as a state we said yes to science we
said yes to vaccines
we said yes to ending this pandemic
we said yes to people's right to vote
without fear of
fake fraud or voter suppression
we said yes
to women's fundamental constitutional
right to decide for herself
what she does with her body
her fate and future
we said yes to diversity
we said yes to inclusion
we said yes to pluralism
we said yes
to all those things that we hold dear as
californians and i would argue as
americans economic justice social
justice racial justice environmental
justice
god i do not like that horrifically fake
man um everything he said there was an
absolute lie we did not say yes we as
californians to those things i'll
actually go through them one time yes to
science okay gavin newsom how many
genders are there because science has
something to do with that so did we say
yes to science or no to science you let
me know
yes to vaccines actually larry elder is
vaccinated himself because he has a
medical condition and often said on the
trail if you want to get vaccinated go
ahead but i'm not going to mandate it
for you so yes to vaccines
i mean yeah i guess you're for forcing
everyone to do what you want them to do
but that was a lie too uh then he says
uh what i scribbled it down really quick
i can't even read what i wrote
oh and the pandemic he said yes to
ending the pandemic well uh you're the
guy that's been in charge for the last
year and a half and obviously it's not
gone so well here because you were
playing commercials saying that larry
elder was gonna kill everybody so you
obviously haven't ended the pandemic so
you're a liar on that one yes to right
to vote
actually
larry is not against people's right to
vote
most sane people except screwball
progressives like you guys just want
people to show ids to vote i did not
have to show an id to vote i could have
walked back into the polling place the
next day and pretended to be my neighbor
because i know his name and address so
the idea that somehow you're protecting
the right to vote is just nonsensical
you said yes to women's rights
you're very concerned what a woman does
with her body now it is true that larry
elder is uh pro-life that's about the
life of the baby not about the life of
the woman
larry wants women to be able to make
whatever medical choices they have they
want to make for themselves
um so that's i'll give you like half on
that one you're a liar but the whole
abortion thing has gotten so messy that
you're you're half a liar on that one
but pretty much yes on diversity oh well
you actually just uh stopped the the
black guy and you're a white privileged
millionaire douchebag and you treated
him horribly and the media pretended he
was a black white supremacist in the
rest of it so that was a lie inclusion i
mean same one it's just one of your
ridiculous phrases pluralism again no
what do you mean pluralism you all think
the same this is not a pluralistic group
of people that voted for you it's a
bunch of clones uh and then all the
things we hold dear i'm fairly certain
gavin newsom none of the things you hold
dear are the things that i hold dear and
i'm at least the citizen in this state
for now uh now on to larry elder uh
thanking his supporters
my opponent governor gavin newsom
come on
let's
let's let's be gracious let's be
gracious in defeat
and by the way
we may have lost
the the battle but we are going to win
the war
will we we'll see we'll see and i look
forward to continuing uh on the
battlefield with larry one way or
another regardless of what state either
one of us live in at that point but if
you watch the rest of larry's speech
he's he's humble he's gracious he's
thankful
um and just to put a final cap on that
and then i know i have a bunch of
questions about you know my future here
in the state and everything else um
he's a good man he's a good man and just
know if if your only takeaway your only
takeaway shouldn't be the california did
the wrong thing the voters spoke okay we
live in a democracy the motor spoke but
your takeaway should be
that they treated this man horribly and
that is what we must fight more than the
political fight in a specific sense that
anyone who dares speak up and does not
fall into their hysterical leftist
socialist orthodoxy will be treated
horribly you could be black and called a
white supremacist they implied that he
assaulted a woman in venice when he was
the one being assaulted everything they
said about him the entire way was a lie
joe biden said he was a trump clone he
was born in south central l.a the son of
a janitor so know that just know that
it's not to sit here and [ __ ] about it
it's to know what they will do and then
figure out what is the best way for you
and your life to react to it and on that
note let's get to some questions i know
a whole bunch of them are about
california and everything else
brad says i hate to ask but what are
your thoughts on the legitimacy of the
vote and what is next for california
now look i said already that you don't
have to show an id the second you don't
have to show an id there's something to
talk about i'm not saying that there was
mass widespread fraud but the second you
don't have to show an id by the way you
have to show an id to get a vaccine
right so they're telling you that you to
get the vaccine which they want you to
get you have to show an id and then
you're gonna have to show that
everywhere you go when you go into
restaurants and everywhere else somehow
that's not racist but if you show an id
if you ask people for an id at a polling
place that's racist everything they say
is a lie at every freaking level um also
this idea of the mail in ballots where
as i said you could literally see
through the envelopes and see if people
voted yes or no it's like this is
something we should at least discuss
right but we won't have a national
discussion because the democrats got
what they wanted so now we can move on
but i think these are things that are
worthy of discussion and by the way
these are things that in red states that
are saying they're working on tightening
up these things not to disenfranchise
people from voting but to ensure that
people feel that their vote actually
counts in any of this matters or is real
kathy says what is your plan to fight
for california or are you leaving in
light of this newsome win uh you know i
talked a bunch about this yesterday and
the truth the absolute truth is we are
trying to figure out what to do i
promised a year and a half ago when i
had that drink with michael knowles that
i would stay and fight and then when
larry got involved it really like amped
up my desire to fight and i think i gave
this thing everything i got and again as
i said yesterday i'm i'm proud of what i
did and i'm incredibly proud of larry
and i'm incredibly proud proud of my
team and all that stuff
um you know there's that much here for
us at this point there there's not much
left here um it's not as easy as me and
david to say we gotta leave we got we
got people and we have employees and
everything else and we're gonna figure
out all those things and uh
yeah i like florida uh sherry says how
can we reach over this entrenched
generation and help our youth being a
grandparent i see my kids puppet the
liberal media talking points and now i
see my grandkids starting to do the same
any ideas this is this is like the
toughest one this is the toughest one i
have a good friend
uh one of my best friends whose mom is
in her 80s and she posted something i
think actually i think i mentioned this
before i'm pretty sure she posted my why
i left the left prageru video on
facebook and she had her grandchildren
attacking her on facebook this is a
woman who have she knows who she is she
watches the show there's a woman who
i've known and loved my whole life who's
80 something years old right now and uh
and she was being attacked by her
grandchildren on facebook and we're all
dealing with this we're all dealing with
generational problems
the political thing that's leaked into
everybody's families i know it i know
it's happening to all of you guys it's
happening to me everyone's struggling
with all of this stuff and we have to
figure out a way to manage it
as for how you can wake up your
grandchildren it's tough i mean this is
partly why prageru does those videos
that they do right because they want to
do
short animated things that might catch a
young person's attention it's hard to
say to them oh no you should read thomas
sol's book like read that
that's tough but if you can get them to
watch something just get get some little
kernel of something um you know make it
your your grandmother and make it
personal when they're saying these
things about everyone being racist and
and old people that that screwed
everything up and all that stuff say
well do you think that of me
do you think that of me as your
grandmother
because most people actually don't but
they're caught in this hysteria and then
of course i can't blame a certain amount
of young people for being being
brainwashed because we know what the
mainstream media in big tech is doing to
people look what they did to larry elder
so if you're force-fed all of the lies
you might start believing lies so we got
work to do we got work to do
tanya says have you spoken to larry
since the election um i have
and we're going to have dinner soon and
i just want to leave it at that what we
spoke about privately we'll stay private
amy says how do we keep positive and
hopeful about the 20
2022 election cycle if we have zero
faith in our elections
i get it this is what i was saying to
you guys yesterday it's like i feel
proud of what i did and i feel good but
i don't think it right right at this
moment i can like be selling you guys on
oh everything's going to be great and
it's all legit and everything else like
they're telling us they're telling us
how they want to destroy the company the
company the country and they're and
they're doing it in front of our eyes
and then when they when you ask for very
basic things like voter id laws they
tell you you're racist and now they tell
you you're diseased on top of it so i
don't know
exactly how you find faith in that but
that's why i would say you have to find
faith in yourself and in people and it
may be in something above you rather
than in these systems and we have to
figure out a way in many ways ironically
this is very much what my my next book
is about uh holly says do you believe
that there will be lawsuits coming out
of this one based on conservative courts
experiencing issues at uh voting
locations
i think there probably will be some but
you know the results it was such a wide
gap that like the media is not going to
pay any attention there will be some
lawsuits and maybe maybe we can get
something done on voter id but the state
is just [ __ ] it's just [ __ ]
kyle why do you think newsome beat this
recall election um look it's it's a
democratic machine here there are way
more democrats for sure but as i said
many democrats were moving over by the
way larry absolutely crushed the other
40 uh opponents in it so this was in a
way in a way a good day for larry elder
and to that extent it's a good day for
all of us because more and more people
know about larry elder so if you're
really doing the long game it's hard to
do long game like the day after an
election
but when once you lick your wounds and
you start moving forward like this was a
good day for the ideas we care about
because more and more people will find
out about larry elder and then maybe
they'll go down that rabbit hole then
maybe they'll watch some crazy right
winger named dave rubin and next thing
you know you're doing self-help with
jordan peterson and then suddenly you
realize you don't need these politicians
to live a better life because it's on
you to figure it out yourself
so that that would be my hope right
there uh i think this next question is
sort of in line with that uh lee says uh
the machine is so tough to beat but i'm
so exceptionally disappointed in the gop
they don't fight for the cities we
cannot win without the cities how can we
do a better job of marketing
conservatism and libertarianism you know
this is a good question because i don't
know exactly what happened
behind the scenes with the gop related
to this recall election but larry from
what i can tell got really no help and
not only larry the rest of the
republicans got pretty much no help from
any mainstream republicans like
literally larry had me he had john
voight he had scott baio uh dan crenshaw
was tweeting about it a lot um but where
were the heavy hitters
maybe and for all i know this is where
i'm not gonna throw anybody on the bus
but like would it have helped if trump
had campaigned or said something i'm not
sure maybe it would have enraged the
democratic base more and i'm sure there
were a lot of negotiations with that
even some of my let's say right leaning
friends you know who they are like
people got very quiet about this maybe
they thought they were going to
instigate the wrong side like i don't
know about all of that but i look i
guess i'm sort of new to the right side
of things but i have no faith in the
republican party that these people are
going to do anything good like if they
didn't see this guy as the right guy to
back in this thing even if it was going
to be maybe they were like oh no it's
just we're going to lose no matter what
so why bother it's like well then i
don't want anything to do with you guys
so i'm not going to sit here and defend
the republicans i think it was pretty
pathetic and you know they have a lot of
work to do if they ever want to turn
this dystopian
state back into a functioning place
eliza says how was your experience
during the campaign how would you
encourage people to get involved locally
look my experience was fantastic it was
absolutely fantastic every moment that i
was out there meeting people talking to
people
uh you know speaking publicly
it was a joy these are good decent
american people they are people who want
to live free i love chatting with people
i miss being out on the road i mean
that's what i missed more in the last
year and a half than anything else has
i've slowly started going back out on
the road for different events again um
so the question is how do how do these
people just not get depressed right now
how do they not all get black filled how
do they all not flee and maybe a good
amount of them are gonna flee and
they would have my blessing and my full
understanding
um but i loved being out there and by
the way there's something to be said
about being the minority in this state
like when you meet other people and
you're like oh you're saying too and
they're all bananas and that's most of
them and you're kind of cool too and and
that's why when we do these reuben
report meetups and we we did one at um
pineapple hill saloon on election night
it's like i'm starting to know these
people and they're knowing each other
and they're making friends and
and uh and dating and all sorts of stuff
and it's like there are sane like-minded
people and sometimes being in the
minority like it's kind of cooler it's
kind of cooler it's the actual
resistance not the hashtag resistance
emmy says some people are partially
blaming trump for the loss of the recall
because he commented commented on it do
you think his getting involved in local
politics in a place like california is
that radioactive or is this more
blame-shifting and demonizing trump i
think it's mostly that right like if
they can figure out a way to say
something about trump and they can
figure out a way to say something
negative about trump they're always
going to figure it out that being said i
just addressed what i think is a legit
thing which is is it possible that the
trump derangement syndrome of these
sun-fried people here in california is
so extraordinary that had he said
anything positive about larry basically
had he campaigned or done anything real
or had any of his surrogates let's say
gone out and done anything real is it
positive is it possible that it would
have
engaged that base to even come out more
it's very possible but i think you just
have to do what you think is right so
again i don't know if larry spoke to
trump i don't know if trump spoke to
larry i don't know what the what the
party was doing and all of those things
but to me if you're in a political war
or any kind of war an ideological war
you go in with everything you got you go
in with everything you got or at least a
game plan to figure out when you're
going to go in with different things and
he larry did not get much help he did
not get much help it's just a fact and
maybe if he'd gotten all the help in the
world we'd still be right where we're at
right now armin says for a complete
change of subject hallelujah would love
to hear if you had any nor mcdonald
experiences in honor of his passing he
was one of a kind and truly fearless he
will greatly be missed yeah he was truly
one of a kind and was probably you know
dennis miller to me was probably the
best weekend update guy that was my like
formative comedy years i think norm
mcdonald took over right after him and i
i think you could put them at one and
two and you could easily argue either
one either way i know chevy chase did it
before them um but he was just so good
and what i loved about norman mcdonald
is when when a joke fell flat which it
did you know there was always one on
weekend update every saturday that
didn't work he would make that funnier
than the joke itself i did meet him once
i think we've got a picture of it i met
him a couple of years ago it was about
five six years ago at aura tv
and uh he came up to me and he goes uh i
can't do a great normal mcdonald's
impression he says something like he's
like ow so uh you're dave rubin right
right people tell me that i sound like
you but uh i think you sound like me
alright then we just chatted for about a
half hour and he was just a good guy we
had agreed that he was going to do the
show and then something happened
but look anyone that that's an actual
funny comic who hasn't lost their mind
in all of this
and who was sort of liked across the
board like it's pretty great pretty
great and i think this last one ali
says what are you atoning for this yom
kippur are you specifically asking
anyone for forgiveness and what are you
thankful for as you head into the new
year so as i said at the top uh i'm not
live right now even though the magic of
youtube makes it seem that i'm live we
are pre-taping this because today is yom
kippur which is the holiest day in the
jewish new year i'm at synagogue as we
speak right now with my friend dennis
prager and some other people um
you know
well i'll tell you the thankful part i'm
thankful for you guys like i really am i
i guess that seems cliche at some level
but i'm thankful that i am like blessed
enough that i can say what i think for
for a living
and a pretty good living and have people
care about it and have people send that
love right back to me and say nice
things to me all the time and it's
expanded my world and i get to know all
kinds of cool people and go to all sorts
of cool things and and have flexibility
in my life to take august off and
everything else and and do all that can
you roll back to the question because i
want to make sure i answer it absolutely
fully you can do that thanks um is there
someone specifically are asking for
forgiveness
i don't think so specifically for
forgiveness um
you know the people i would say if i
wronged anyone in this past year it
might be with a little bit of hyperbolic
talk related to politics but usually i
do that in a sarcastic way that i think
it's pretty obvious when i'm joking or
not so i i don't think i've wronged
anyone sort of in my personal life i
really don't um and what are you atoning
for that's a good one what are you
atoning for so it is the day of
atonement like what are you kind of
saying i i did wrong in this past year
and i gotta do better
next year
um
i guess the best thing that i can do
for this coming year this 5782 that's a
lot of years
that the jews have been around
this 5782 i guess uh
i guess doing this better than i can do
it better than i've done it so far i
don't know if that's not an atonement
exactly it's sort of more of like uh
that's almost like a new year's eve like
what am i going to do better this year
but if i if i did anything
in this
studio that uh that wasn't as good as it
should have been um i
my hope is that i will do better that's
not the greatest answer but so much of
my life is wrapped up in this thing
right here you guys get to see it unfold
every day so that that really is the
answer um all right everybody we are
back tomorrow with a round table haven't
done one in a couple weeks but it's all
about canada and they have some
elections coming up if you thought our
uh california elections are crazy wait
till you hear about some of the canada
elections uh viva fry lawyer who's been
on the show a couple times great guy
who's actually running for the for uh a
seat in uh i think he lives in calgary
if i'm not mistaken western canada for
sure uh and then ezra levant from the
rebel will be on and we're working on
maxine bernier hopefully the schedule
will allow it also part three of my
interview with rose mcgowan is up and uh
and by the way next week i'm going to
new york city i have some family stuff
so i may tape some stuff while i'm sort
of on the road there but then we'll be
back in studio after that and as always
i thank you guys for your support i know
this week was
not exactly the way we wanted it to turn
out but
politics isn't everything you you just
keep going and you find those wins where
you can so have a great day everybody
and if you want to play along
reubenreport.locals.com